c'est loupé
chaque année 6 g si si j'ai bien
[Applaudissements]
à
monsieur chat
bouchard
chers amis chers années chez si je vous
si je vous ai bien compris si je vous ai
bien compris vous êtes en train de dire
à la prochaine fois
[Applaudissements]
bien autant mais en attendant avec la
même sérénité que toute notre tout notre
comportement pendant la campagne il faut
quand même avaler cette fois ci c'est
pas facile je me kiffe
je m'excuse je suis arrivé je m'excuse
d'avoir attendu pour venir vous trouver
je dois vous avouer que je continue
espéré pendant longtemps parce que si
dois je dois vous dire que je dois vous
dire que c'est dur ça fait plus mal ça
fait mal plus profondément que n'importe
quelle défaite électorale
chez de quoi je parle
heureusement
je voudrais
chut je dois vous demander d'écouter un
tout petit peu ce que je crois qu'on
doit se dire à la fin de la campagne
il est clair il est clair admettons leur
que la balle vient d'être envoyé dans le
camp fédéraliste
[Applaudissements]
non le peuple le peuple québécois vient
le peuple québécois vient nettement de
lui donner encore une autre chance
il appartiendra il appartiendra dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent aux
fédéralistes et d'abord à monsieur
trudeau lui même
et là il leur appartiendra de mettre un
contenu dans les promesses qu'ils ont
multiplié depuis 35 jours
[Musique]
ils ont tous ils ont tous proclamé que
si le non l'emportait le statu quo était
mort et enterré
et que les québécois n'auraient pas à
s'en repentir
en attendant en attendant de voir ce qui
s'en suivent